We are almost ready to
define the class NP.
First, however, we need to define
running time for a non-deterministic
machine, because it operates
differently from a deterministic one.
Since we think about these possible
computations running in parallel,
the running time for
each computation path is the path
length from the initial configuration.
And the running time of
the machine of the whole,
is the maximum number of steps used
on any branch of the computation.
Note that once we have a bound on the
length of any accepting configuration
sequence, we can avoid looping
just by creating a time out.
NP, then, is the set of languages
recognized by an order n to the k
nondeterministic Turing machine,
where k is some natural number.
Or, in other words, it's the set of
languages recognized in polynomial time
by a non-deterministic machine.
NP stands for
non-deterministic polynomial time.
Non-determinism can be
a little confusing, but
it helps to remember that a string
is recognized if it leads to
any accepting computation, ie,
any accepting path in this tree.
Not that any Turing Machine that is
a polynomial recognizer for a language,
can easily be turned into a polynomial
decider by adding a timeout,
since all accepting computations
are bounded in length by a polynomial.